you
less than 10 seconds for a third hourly
bullet in a row all right let's see what
we get in this one another 26 minute
tournament 66 players at the start of
this one let's see if I could play some
correct chess no no not correct chess
but
what am I trying to say some aggressive
chess let's try this as a start
f4 I like my Queens post
okay this is a trading machine this is a
trading machine that we have here
they're gonna give me the bishop I'm
fine with this structure their Knights
gonna find it difficult no I have
something to pinpoint I could chase
their rook away
rip d2 here there poke around at these
pieces actually bishop here's what I
want to do ooh
it's running right into skewer town I
will take that first we're gonna go here
preparing to take and then challenge
further that's a bad idea by me I'm up a
pond though no yeah no no back to basics
pac-man mode though look at that rook
you got this oh no I have to connected
to connected guys
they moved I didn't see it keep movin
check and then there all right picked up
the rook they're gonna resign back to
tournament - all right
Magnus Kasparov 12 is in there a player
that we probably have to fear I would
think
all right wardrobe wardrobe has been up
at the top there for many tournaments
now okay quick night g3 they're allowing
this it's pinpoint that week square jump
in are you oh wow you don't get that too
often you had two chances to take the
Queen and your opponent gave you a
second opportunity that's rare man rare
castles 'if I've kingside castles let's
still do this and give up f6 who cares
about that right it's pretty scary
square right here their knight is pinned
oh where is he going he has to come back
here now we're gonna go here and then
look for this stop 94 how about we just
go here keep the H file closed
no you do that and get back here
hit the night okay hmm
the pawn is pinned I want to get to this
square now we're looking at me inching
into those dark squares slithering in
five five and a ton of force still go
with e4 Karel Khan was this the guy
played in the last round last tournament
we're no queenside there you go
kick that night away for f4 f5 g4 maybe
now let's do this I should have done
this sooner this is a super strong night
I'm on there bishop in comes g4 I'm on
there bishop tactics Bishop takes
they're gonna really take my knight
I think they're getting mated woo oh
they have that move now there's two
pieces on that Square back determine
that was pretty quick I'll take it nine
three eights and a five I'm in there one
of the eights less than 21 a hundred and
three players in this one
okay gotta watch out for some extreme
tactics against this guy that's a pretty
cool name extreme tactic it's a
memorable one
okay playing within the structure are we
in a sack here that would be pretty
extreme huh not quite sure what that
last move was doing oh okay let's open
this up a little bit now that they've
weakened their diagonal let's focus on
these dark squares and Bishop is a
pretty strong monster there might be
replaced with the super Knight
here we go
keep control over that Center take with
the knight set up discoveries and yeah
difficult piece to work around is my
knight break down this position over
here okay super Knight hmm Knight g4
I mean takes pawn queen do this my
knight back to f5 maybe not the best way
to approach that and I hang on to that
guy hang on to him
oh they have really good activity with
their King don't they and I get this
pawn at least I get this guy gotta get a
pawn
hi there in time I am in there in time I
have a fast pond out there down on time
that was an extreme Mouse race I'd say
uh cap mate says so extreme very afraid
all right I got 12 three twelves are up
there three-way tie for first all right
Oh Mouse lip
I wanted h4 h5 stuff I also wanted a
Bishop to e3 what can you do okay let's
focus on c4 and drop in their sacred hmm
I'm fearful of f4 I want some play
against their center in Queen h5
actually let's go here it's gonna be
sensitive
uh yeah I gotta defend here I can't move
that pawn um oh my bishop is hit
yikes scary let's go here
twenty seconds there Bishop is a monster
and a half on d5 they're thinking though
they're definitely thinking Bishop takes
pawn is working mm-hmm a lot of stuff is
working here and I gotta I gotta give
some material back actually I kind of
weasel out there don't I I got the
exchange you lucky dog you oh wow
lucky lucky lucky you clock player 16 16
16 15 16 minutes left
124 of you are here all right GM GM who
Grindelwald all righty
all right I get upon can I convert it
stay on this square get head
that guy out of there that's prepared to
push right in the center be very direct
get a flight square in and be prepared
to play d4 I also do this I'm avoiding
the Queen exchange definitely don't want
to allow them to have a passed pawn
Knight in the center knight on e4 knight
on c3 stops Knight d2 my last move
Knight c3 with d4 I don't know that
quite sure if that's to him it's afraid
of some tactics against my bishop all
right now their Knight is a [ __ ]
stranded isn't it and go with this move
takes with the pawn and then here I'm
gonna shy away from that that's a little
afraid of some pressure against my king
this is a good square for my knight to
defend here a little bit I guess rook f4
huh oh let's take him out challenge
their queen they don't have any time
pick up a pond they're starting to fly
but they don't have any time twenty two
twenty nineteen I'm in second 133
players a bullet robot 1999 as an air
CAPTCHA 2002 is on board
let's try Sicilian all right there we go
an on mouse slip each pawn attack uh-oh
I already get the light square bishop
take them
and let's play d6 before Knight f6 see
going okay Knight takes pawn and then I
have this let's do it now they're not
reacting how do I complete development
let's go here mean trade you should
avoid it
oh I missed that I was on their Queen
they resigned back to tournament twenty
four two point lead less than thirteen
135 is in this one
energy seventy-three alien black and
third hard pawn secrets is on board they
center counter the center counter that
is a name okay I'm gonna take develop
and grab a tempo against their Queen
soon don't get made it on each two or is
their Queen gonna go anywhere another
Knight twice let's challenge this guy
he's a bug keep my Bishop challenged
their Bishop I guess they're gonna be
going there hmm
it's surprising no I got to take him out
my light squares are weak opposite color
bishops hang on to him get my rook to
the seventh stop Bishop f3 let's do that
first approve my king position and
defend f3 God defend that pawn I think
it's coming all the way back actually
III was wrong with the e3 and we're
getting right back to e3 I guess we're
gonna have
opposite color Bishop ending soon unless
that move is played hmm I'm gonna give
up a pawn
just to get my Bishop active Bishop
takes pawn incoming okay can I go faster
and we have 14 seconds then I'm going to
defend that let's keep the rook around
oh they have that move rook check on
their bishop
it's a time race I have the faster Mouse
and that's about it
28 26 23 I don't believe my opponent
offered a draw if he did I don't know if
I would even have time to even go and
click on it and risk a mouse slip of
accepting it
bullet robot no I'm pretty sure neither
I know I didn't offer a draw but clearly
that was a super dead draw position
frenched arash less than 10 left in this
term and I have a two-point lead over
wardrobe okay we're gonna go with Queen
e2 and clean side Castle actually there
knight on e7 is a little bit weird
weaken my light squares significantly
centralized jump a knight in there how
about Knight a5 okay now we're cooking
get rid of that night hmm I could take
and I'll be defending this bishop it's
the only vulnerable point really in my
position I want to have that square for
a queen check I'm not playing this well
all right clean here clean takes here
and we're threatening a million to one
- with the help of this guy actually
back to tournament 3230 27-24 less than
nine I think we're gonna get picked I
thought that get that guy that's in a
tie with me at 32 I thought he just
finished so I am mistaken to think we're
gonna get paired up not the case okay
queenside castle I think I could do that
a little bit scary for a moment there
when I was in a pin um I think I want my
night on d6r this we're gonna have Queen
trades my King needs to improve I want
to prepare to meet b5 and get this in
okay um
do this mmm that is very helpful
getting over here now my other rook
starts to invade sweeping up a lot of
pawns here now I could start pushing one
of them and get behind him push away
that collapse pretty quick for light I
guess they're gonna resign I still have
plenty of time here or or are they gonna
resign or am I getting no no fried back
to tournament 36 34 30 - 26 all right Oh
a mouse lips start to this one we're
gonna try and make it work all right
let's transfer this guy over here
let's give my bishop doing something
first
I don't know here Wow
scary very scary yeah I don't know here
they're ready to push i weak in my
position quite a bit with my move
g4 clearly hmm I don't know
my mother Queen and now I'm able to
remedy my light squares a bit better I
get this guy out of the way open up my
bishop have a pivot square on e6 g5 is
also there rook takes Bishop is an idea
let's go here
this is collapsing getting some material
now G takes f o to follow they just
cashed out here still looking for this
kind of stuff okay the clock is ticking
less than five on the tournament clock
call it and they're down on time back to
term in 42 40 36 33 the guy that's in
first is currently playing a game
do I have to consider berserk not a good
opponent to really try and preserve
against I don't think okay one of these
huh let's see where that Bishop wants to
go right there huh we're gonna get that
Bishop pair though I thought at least
okay I still want to get Knight f4 in
there oh let's do this actually anything
wrong with that
hmm I could take that b7 pawn you goof
take them now too late to do that I
could take on g7 as well my knight is a
strong piece on the rook and a run back
let's just get out of that for a moment
I'm on the rook Knight h5 to f6 I have
my back rank covered well enough still
Knight f6 now this is super deadly fact
I'm on the bishop I'm just seeing that
now 246 on the tournament clock right
here
deadly move is this does this guy know
to fry me last time oh man
zanny er that's back-to-back I'm
starting to believe it's not like
Comcast gambit stuff
but Nonna fry stuff
okay 46 44 36 he still has a two-point
lead this is the pack leader so I have
my chance to hunt this guy down all
right okay I have a fast track at this
let's do this first at the minority
attack I should have continued they're
gonna sacrifice here what's the matter
with me that was no good mm-hmm
cover this stuff no it's that night
doing actually huh
I could take though okay on push I get
that move in there hmm I could do that
move actually because when I take I get
here that can't get behind it so what
does this mean I get that move in I get
this check-in and I could get this move
in with check now the clock still not an
easy one to pull off maybe maybe now it
is if I get night here they're stopping
that though but I poked around like this
and then go like that okay I got this
pawn okay know how to win this no I got
this one
time no stalemates three seconds six
seconds left I will take it right at the
end there was only six seconds left to
the game clock oh just in the nick of
time overtook that guy who has been at
the top of the think the past two
tournaments who I'll take it
alright I got 13 games in he got 15
Paulo Malo got 12 48
46 36 poof tight game tight game I
should have never played h6 even if it
isn't objectively correct and bullet
like that everybody should sack on that
age 6 square huh
alright good games all there were 158
that one poof